[Applause]
thank you so good to be back I bet you
will never guess who flew on the Lolita
Express former President Bill Clinton
will reportedly be unmasked as doe 36
do in Jeffrey Epstein court documents
that are expected to be released this
week this of course comes as a total
surprise to absolutely no one and by no
one I mean her
[Laughter]
according to ABC News Clinton was
mentioned in more than 50 of the
redacted filings only 50 huh someone
needs more balance of
nature now I know what you're thinking
that's a lot of frequent flyer miles to
pedo Island but many of those 50
instances reportedly pop up only in
conversation specifically whether or not
to subpoena Clinton as part of an old
lawsuit however one of Epstein's victims
says she actually saw Bill Clinton Go
off into the night with a beautiful
woman on each arm h a beautiful woman on
each arm well I guess we know it wasn't
Hillary and
Chelsea yeah when they go off into the
night it's on a two-seated
broom for his part bill has always
denied being on the island but he also
denied many things like having sexual
relations with that woman and hating his
[Laughter]
wife
you don't deserve that joke we actually
obtained some of the court documents
though and there here are some names
that only got partially unmasked like
this one
here I wonder who that could be I don't
know then there's this
one this is a
Puzzler this
one uh
apparently he was only there for the
snacks and I don't know what this one is
let's see I no idea that is clearly a
[Music]
typo Rob what are your thoughts here uh
do you think that the shoe has dropped
the good thing about this is is that we
saw so many fake lists on Twitter so now
we're going to get the real thing look
nobody's surprised that Bill Clinton was
on that island right it's not like he's
not breaking not like Fox News Alert
guess what so the names on the list of
people names we know there's a
difference between people on the island
and people on the plane really some
names of people on the plane that
includes some you know what so you're
saying that the plane went somewhere
else like to I don't know
Donald you know once or twice coming
back from uh Miami or coming somewhere
so the these this is all going to come
out the reality about this stuff is that
like this this is like a what's amazing
to me is that this is a really really
rich guy nobody's ever explained to me
where the money came from nobody knows
where the money came from and like
there's all these other rich people
going to the island and nobody ever
asked what do he what did he invent what
did he make what did he like do like
nobody knows knew anything about this
guy like would you actually go to
somebody's Island who and you didn't
know how they got rich that's like a
Bond movie definitely that's a Bond
movie you would never do that if if I
was if they were putting the bill and I
knew they'd be food I would be there it
would be like You' be hunted like game
it's like this is a horror movie that's
my dream all right I think the better
question is how to get Bill Clinton off
the
island I mean once he was there right
right it's like Bill you got to leave
sooner or later bill you they're going
to look for
you do you think um Epstein killed
himself you know the the evidence is
just so overwhelming that he was by
himself in his cell and there was just
no one else around and he was so
destroyed over all those years of just
molesting kids that he called down to
the guard he said hey can you help me
kill myself while I'm down here oh come
on listen there's no doubt about what
happened there everything in the jail
breaks that could see this guy and the
next morning he wakes up he's got a
broken leg a broken arm he strangled
himself to death there's a gun somewhere
in the I mean yeah come on he no that
was that was a nice Clinton almost
murder yes yes cat uh what what do you
make of this story what do you make of
these Revelations
never mind what Rob long said about it
not being a big deal we work at Fox let
me remind you well I think maybe we
might have been a little hard on Hillary
Clinton for not being able to be
relatable when she was running for
president CU like it's not what my life
is like like what was the over Christmas
she was probably like sweetie Grandpa's
a little stressed out right now cuz all
the speculation he took a private jet to
a place colloquially known as pedophile
Island mhm that's not what my house was
like over the holidays I don't know I
don't think most people's life was like
that but Rob is right to the point where
this has been discussed so many times
that for most people for average people
it's just this crazy salacious thing but
like they knew this guy they hung out
with this guy you know Maxwell was at
Chelsea Clinton's wedding after he was
convicted of the sex crimes with minors
the first time
so I don't know how you can like get in
of course she can't get in front of a
camera and be like I'm just like you no
you're not I I wonder Epstein referred
to it as pedophile Island that's
terrible marketing yeah well depends on
who you're talking to apparently exactly
some people it's like uh Happy Island
and the other one is like bleile Island
Joe uh is it true that you frequently
visited Epstein's Island uh no Greg that
is not true if I were on uh Epstein's
Island I had have blown the whistle on
that whole operation immediately the
second I saw a bunch of unsupervised
teenagers hanging around a swimming pool
okay that is a recipe for horse
play and the only chicken fights I like
are ones over leftover
Popeyes I'll say this Greg it seems to
me like Bill Clinton like what's the
point of getting rich by buking Haiti
with your fake charity if you're going
to just like take free rides on other
people's planes you know and yeah like I
get why people are curious about this
because there were all these pedophiles
with in this island and they've got like
one mysterious dead guy and one
conviction yeah it's crazy my question
Greg is how how was the island was it
nice no you know it's overrated you know
what you guys want to do after the show
read my Yelp
review I only give it two and a half
Stars well you know they were rude to me
anyway hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else